you know things are bad when the liberal
media starts turning on a Democrat
Biden's already beleaguered White House
getting smacked with three huge skating
pieces this week showcasing the
dysfunction and how his administration
is struggling with getting messaging out
in front of the big issues case in point
raging inflation Joe Biden's boasting
about today's job report the U.S economy
adding 390 000 jobs for the month of May
with an unemployment rate at 3.6 percent
but all of those gains snuffed out by
the highest inflation in four decades
and record high gas prices that's not
stopping Biden from trying to spin the
news
with today's uh excellent jobs report
and unemployment remaining at near
historic lows of 3.6 percent because of
the enormous progress we've made on the
economy the Americans can tackle
inflation from a position of strength
the two challenges on the minds of most
Working Families are prices at the pump
and prices at the grocery store
both of these challenges have been
directly exacerbated by Putin's war in
Ukraine this is
so there's your Victory lap kellyanne do
you think that's a risky Victory lap you
could stumble to finish line as soon as
I don't know as many are predicting a
recession could be right around the
corner
it's a failing strategy for some reason
the only person not paying attention to
all these polls is Joe Biden and his
white house I've never seen such a
clear-cut case for how to respond to
what the American people say is most
important to them and that's the key
about Americans you don't tell them
what's important to them they tell you
and they're telling us inflation
immigration in Joe Biden's America
mothers can't find infant formula nobody
believes Vladimir Putin for that and and
he loses America when he doesn't just
stand up and say look it's been a little
bit rough but we have a plan we're going
to get out of this look at all the polls
it's not just that people feel uncertain
about their current economic situation
well it's that when they project forward
the pessimism is there they think it
will only get worse and if Republicans
keep recruiting candidates that are
talking about how to fix the economy how
to get back to energy Independence how
to put conservative judges that don't
think the Constitution is a paper towel
on the bench they'll do very well this
fall but Joe Biden and Kamala Harris do
less every weekend than almost everyone
I know there's never anything on her
public schedule we see where he is I
mean he literally had a a 17-minute gun
Ranger last night in prime time and left
didn't go to Congress and say Hey Now I
want to get everybody together and show
people working in the cabinet room
Kamala Harris is is nowhere they're
embarrassed to put her out there and I
think that the media has had enough of
them because the media covered for them
they worked overtime to help them get
where they are and they're not getting
enough transparency in return on that
note so judge it can't be overlooked in
addition to this these stories about Joe
being upset about the walk backs or even
some stories about black staffers being
upset within the White House there's
also the Washington Post for the first
time acknowledging the hunter Biden
laptop story what's going on well I
think the Washington Post understands
that they survive based upon the number
of newspapers that they sell that
they're that their customer is the
person who buys the newspaper and not
the White House and you know with Joe
Biden complaining so much about and
trying to tell us what a great jobs
report look American people as kellyanne
said you know we tell them how we feel
but American people understand that they
can't go to the supermarket anymore
without looking at a piece of meat
putting it down and then maybe picking
it up again it's crazy I mean I even
look at me and say is that right but
what Joe Biden ought to do instead of
complaining about his staff he ought to
take 15 minutes and say sit down with
the American people and say you know
what this is what I want to say to you
this is how I want to do it I feel your
pain I got into office because I felt
your pain about coven I empathized with
you if he's so upset about the people
around him do something about it Joe
you're the boss do something so I think
he's saying that he's annoyed with
people around him he's annoyed that he
didn't know about the baby formula early
well you know what pull in your press
secretary and tell her you better either
be on the same page with me or don't be
on the same page but Harold why is the
median not covering for Joe Biden now
well I don't think they've ever covered
for him I'm sorry I won't let Greg talk
I changed my mind
I'm kidding the floor is yours
at so you know Ron Klein has complaining
about CNN and and others he thinks not
treating them fairly look these resets
happen in White House this happened in
Trump's White House this happened in
Obama's White House it happened in
George W on Clinton's and hw's white
house
um and you have to have you have to have
the dexterity to be able to push a reset
and to be able to figure out if you're
not getting the right advice about baby
formula then you fired the people that
are giving you've had advice or you put
people in charge that can help run these
things I would I would remind everybody
and the baby the baby uh formula piece
it was a safety and health issue that
got them to shut some of that stuff down
now he should have known those things
earlier look on oil and gas I applaud
them from wanting to me with the Saudis
and the Venezuelans I don't think that's
a long-term strategy but certainly in
the intermediate as we ramp up
production here in America and find ways
to eventually graduate to a different
kind of platform energy platform you got
to give them credit there where I think
he has to understand is that the Border
and crime or issues are going to
resonate with voters and they have to
get a better strategy around that I
don't the strategy is not as clear to me
around no around those two issues as it
is inflation uh and oil and gas Greg I
like it when Joe Biden uh tax inflation
by defining it for us right what we're
seeing is an increase in prices
[Laughter]
but they have to admit the problem is
the message it's not the execution it's
the substance itself uh but um you asked
this question a couple of times like why
is the media changing why is the media
attacking them
I don't think the media is turning on
him per se I think they realize that he
has served his purpose he got elected as
an old white safe moderate Trojan Horse
designed to hide the coming Reckoning of
the woke the wokists that were inside
that Trojan Horse so now they don't need
the feeble old coot and could gently
push him out into the pasture that's why
they're talking about Hunter Biden all
the time a story that they buried and
now they're so brave cover covering all
of the these sorted details that I've
been all over since day one but you know
why you know why you're going to know
that that the media is not like isn't
suddenly in our camp or on our side when
they all decide that January 6th hearing
is going to be in prime time you don't
think that's a political strategy in
which the Democrats and the media
collude together sound familiar right
they're doing it on prime time for a
reason they're doing it because they've
got nothing else but they're going to be
in for their own they're going to be in
for a lousy surprise when no one watches
well I feel bad that I've interrupted
Harold several times we're only two
segments into the show so Harold would
you like to read my tease
Harold looking back do you think they
should have covered for Hunter Biden do
you think the laptop being called
Russian disinformation who was there who
was the media the Twitter taken New York
Post off I mean in curiosity 51
elections I don't know what national
security Guy saying this is Russian
disinformation kellyanne I think you I
reckon this is the wrong person I think
that all this stuff should be
transparent for him we're trying to
think President Biden I think Greg has
the answer to that is that he served so
no regrets he served his purpose hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else